- and what a difference a week makes
that's what I have to say last week
after the show people will call him it
said bill you really kind of want a pet
they're doubling down on Trump as a
traitor
even after the Muller report came out
well ape [ __ ] doesn't look so bad this
week I mean people would last week those
that come on if Barr was shading the
report wouldn't Muller's team say
something well this week they did say
something so unroll your eyes and go
reef uh cure self yeah Muller's team
started to leak this week to their to
say that the report was a lot worse than
we thought an attorney general
Scissorhands didn't let us see the real
deal and he's still busy redacting you
know by the time we see this it's going
to be covered in more black ink than the
governor of Virginia in 1984
they're right always safe to groan first
anyway but you know it could be that
that bar winds up doing what James Comey
did remember at the end of the Hilary
investigation comes out and he says even
though Hillary didn't do anything
criminal
here's every little thing Hillary did
wrong I thought a feeling bar might do
the same thing he might come out and say
even though it's what Trump did is in
criminal here's every little thing
Hillary did wrong but here's some news
Democrats finally got is about time
officially have asked for Trump's tax
returns and that Trump said could I give
you a short summary from William Bar
today no Trump said I would love to
comply just excuse Rep but I'm being
audited I'm sorry the government can't
see my taxes because the government is
looking at them I mean if he has nothing
to hide then why not release the tax
returns I mean after all a tax return is
just a birth certificate for your money
so Trump did what he always does when
he's in hot water he changes the subject
to his favorite subject it gets his base
going the border
he's door a week long I'm gonna shut
down the border and then then he heard
I'm hearing somebody told him that would
destroy our economy and that half a
million people crossed the border every
day that's that's more than all the
weird Chinese ladies were wandering
around mar-a-lago Wow these people who
won the election on security yeah a 32
year old woman from China obviously a
spy got into mar-a-lago they just
assumed she was the rub-and-tug lady she
she says she could want to use the pool
no bathing suit she has four cell phones
a hard drive and mal infected thumb
drive this is not only a threat to
national security but to all the guests
who are legitimately there to bribe the
president
did you know the president was here
today in LA okay yes he was here for a
roundtable fundraiser get this which
cost you to get a seat at that table one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars he
needs that money to defeat the elitists
yeah it's amazing you know he's been to
this state three times
Obama was here to LA 40 times once just
to take Biden to the Grauman's Chinese
Theater so he could put his hands all
over this amenities and gentlemen and
the cement has come forward to say it
felt terrible about it
and it was crying in its car after no
Biden is still at large women are being
urged to walk at night in pairs I just
want to make that clear no he was out
did you see job Bynes a finally emerge
he came very close
so this close to saying he was about to
run but we still don't know if that's
true we do know it's true that his hands
have been part of an exploratory
committee for decade but you know you
know we're getting a little nitpicky I
mean of course no one likes to be
touched
unwanted leann women get a lot more of
that than men but the first person who
brought this up said he made her feel
gross and uneasy yeah you know what
makes me feel gross than Daisy a second
trump term
he's not Harvey Weinstein or r.kelly
he's more like the TSA and it's getting
ridiculous a woman before today and
judge she was touched by one of his
beaches
you